Traductor: Claudia Viveros
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Entre 1930 y 1961, miles de personas
fueron encarceladas, torturadas
y asesinadas
bajo la dictadura de Rafael Trujillo
en la República Dominicana.
Tres hermanas encabezaron
una revolución clandestina.
Pero aunque su valentía inspiró a muchos,
esta amenazaba al hombre en el poder
y sus vidas pronto tendrían
un final trágico.
Trujillo ascendió de los rangos militares
durante la ocupación de EE. UU.
en la República Dominicana.
Tomó el poder en 1930 mediante
un golpe de Estado y una elección amañada,
y creó un sistema que lo enriquecía
a él y a sus aliados.
La familia de Trujillo sola
controlaba tres quintos
del producto interior bruto,
incluyendo monopolios de sal,
carne de res y periódicos.
Le puso su nombre a la capital del país
y deseaba que su retrato
se mostrara en todas las casas.
Y cometió atrocidades, incluyendo
la masacre de miles de haitianos.
Mientras tanto, una fuerza de policía
secreta mantenía su poder
intimidando a sus oponentes
en el país y en el extranjero.
Las hermanas Mirabal crecieron
en una familia de clase media en el campo.
Sus padres enviaron a las cuatro hermanas,
Patria, Dedé, Minerva y María Teresa
a uno de los mejores internados del país.
Allí, Minerva tuvo un amigo cuyo familiar
fue asesinado por órdenes de Trujillo.
Ella comenzó a buscar
fuertes voces opositoras
y a discutir los problemas de opresión
y justicia con sus hermanas.
Dedé se mantuvo fuera de la política,
pero Minerva, Patria y María Teresa
se dedicaron a cambiar a su país.
Sin embargo, la seguridad de la familia
Mirabal pronto colapsó.
En 1949, fueron invitadas
a una de las fiestas de Trujillo,
las cuales le funcionaban como terreno
de cacería de mujeres jóvenes.
Declinar la invitación no era una opción.
Pese a los intentos de Minerva
para eludirlo en la recepción,
finalmente bailó con Trujillo
pero rechazó sus insinuaciones.
La familia Mirabal abandonó
la fiesta temprano,
lo cual casi nadie hacía y se consideraba
una falta de respeto al dictador.
Su padre, Enrique, fue encarcelado
y la propiedad de la familia confiscada.
Minerva se graduó
con los más altos honores
al ser la primera mujer del país
en recibir un grado en leyes.
Pero se le negó la autorización
del Estado para ejercerlo,
algo de lo que Trujillo se encargó.
Cuando estudiaba, Minerva conoció
a Manolo Tavárez Justo.
Él compartía sus convicciones políticas
y se casaron en 1955.
Ellos vieron brotar las revoluciones
armadas en toda América latina.
Después de que Trujillo destrozara
un intento para derrocarlo en 1959,
ellos comenzaron a preparar
su propia revolución.
Las hermanas Mirabal y sus esposos crearon
el Movimiento Revolucionario 14 de Junio
junto con muchos otros de clase media.
Apodadas Las Mariposas,
las tres organizaron y asistieron
a reuniones clandestinas
y distribuyeron panfletos que detallaban
las violaciones de Trujillo.
En enero de 1960,
juntaron a representantes de todo el país
para establecer la infraestructura
del movimiento y preparar una revuelta.
Pero esta nunca ocurriría.
Trujillo tenía espías por todos lados.
Pronto, muchos revolucionarios, incluidas
Minerva y María Teresa, fueron arrestados.
Durante ese tiempo, Patria descubrió
formas creativas de transmitir información
de y para los rebeldes encarcelados.
Temeroso de perder el apoyo
de EE. UU. y la Iglesia,
que recientemente había
comenzado a criticarlo,
Trujillo liberó a las hermanas
pero mantuvo a los esposos encarcelados.
Pero ellas siguieron amenazado
la estabilidad de su régimen... y su ego.
El 25 de noviembre,
cuando las tres hermanas regresaban
de visitar a dos de sus esposos en cárcel,
los hombres de Trujillo
detuvieron el auto.
Las hermanas y el conductor,
Rufino de la Cruz,
fueron asfixiados y golpeados hasta morir.
Los hombres volcaron el Jeep desde una
colina para hacerlo parecer un accidente.
Patria tenía 36, Minerva 33,
y María Teresa 25.
Pero el plan de Trujillo para silenciar
a las hermanas Mirabal
y así estabilizar su régimen
resultó contraproducente.
Mucha gente no se dejó engañar
por ese encubrimiento endeble.
La comunidad internacional
condenó el asesinato.
EE. UU. cerró su embajada dominicana
e investigó secretamente
el movimiento anti-Trujillo.
Meses más tarde, antiguos miembros
de la milicia dominicana
mataron al dictador, lo que puso fin
a 31 años de su violento mandato.
Gracias a su familia, en especial
a su hermana sobreviviente, Dedé,
el legado de las hermanas Mirabel superó
a las garras de la tiranía de Trujillo
incluso mucho después de su muerte.
Hoy en día, las hermanas Mirabal
son heroínas nacionales
con monumentos en su honor
que conmemoran su lucha.
En 1999, las Naciones Unidas
declararon el 25 de noviembre,
el aniversario de sus muertes,
el Día Internacional de la Eliminación
de la Violencia contra la Mujer.
Su valiente lucha por la justicia
ha inspirado a generaciones.